the first five minutes you're bored
and you're thinking
i can't i'm not gonna be able to sit
here for another five minutes
and before you know it you're there for
two hours three hours and it's riveting
it's unbelie
who would have thought to do that
who was the artist that did the lacma
lights chris
yeah so he did that
yeah chris chris brooke right yeah chris
i love him i love him right chris
burton's i would have never expected
that to be as
iconographic and as popular as it is he
did something that somehow
captured the imagination of people and
transcended
it being one a spectacle and two a work
of art it's something beyond that
because on some level it's like
a bunch of lights what's the big deal
with that
and on another level it's
i mean it's not art what is it well it's
a place people like to go to well
less like a ride at coney island what's
the difference
you know i don't know but art sometimes
uh connects to people in ways that we
don't really anticipate or or understand
there's just something about art that
i don't know you just
it
like
like duchamp's uh urinal
you know he puts this urinal in a room
in a museum and
it's done
you could copy that and do something you
know put something else in there that
would be so ridiculous
but he did it it's done
he put a urinal in an army scene it's
very famous
so
painters and sculptors as filmmakers
they do something and sometimes you
can't you can't you can analyze it all
you want but
there's an area that's unexplainable
and i love the light thing that i mean i
love to see people there
uh i remember there was a
what was it it wasn't a blackout but it
was something and it was it was the only
thing in the area that was lit
and people were just
having so much fun there
so
you know it's weird it's just
have you have you seen the car thing
the cars haven't been to lacma in a
little bit oh i don't know if the cars
are still there
did you see the film with the guy with
the time with the clock it was called
the clock
and it exactly
went with the time on clocks and it was
a 24-hour film
didn't see that one
i mean it
it was an experience
i i i
i went i was in paris a year later and
it was being held in paris at the time
but it's just a series of shots from
movies that have a clock in them a time
and as you watch it the time on the
clock is exactly what time it is
over a 24-hour period so it begins in
the morning and it ends at midnight
um
you know it begins at
well it begins at midnight but then it
ends at midnight uh
the first five minutes you're bored
and you're thinking
i can't i'm not going to be able to sit
here for another five minutes and before
you know it you're there for two hours
three hours and it's riveting it's
unbelie
who would have thought to do that
it's called the clock i mean it's it's
in the beginning you couldn't see it all
24 hours because you could only see it
during the hours that the museum was
open
so if the museum opened at nine in the
morning and it closed at eight at night
at eight at night
they would say okay folks you gotta
leave or you'd get there at eight in the
morning you could see it from eight but
you would never get to see what happened
after eight or
after midnight you know
but then the closing so i'd gone several
times and saw two or three hours of it
at different times
and then they said they were going to
show all 24 hours at the museum the last
day
and i was there for the whole 24 hours
oh wow and at the end
there were i would say a quarter of the
theater were people who'd been there the
whole time
and
when it was over with we all stood up
and cheered
and were hugging each other like you
made it and
it was one of those transcendence
experiences i've never forgotten it
and it's utterly ridiculous
i mean who would want to watch that
every every scene was two seconds five
seconds maybe 10 seconds
and it was a clock it could be someone
looked at their wrist watch could be a
grandfather clock clock on a train
station just scenes that had no
connection at all
how could you watch five hours of that
it became mesmerizing it was
unbelievable i tell you one of
one of the most amazing things i ever
saw
what year was this
two thousand
something
early
maybe twenty years ago
something like that
yeah
citizen lachma okay but i i don't know
if when they'll show it again but if
they will people will go to you know
it toured all over the world
so
but your question was about
you know when an artist creates
something you you never know what's
going to happen
you never know what's going to catch
people's imagination i don't even know
why we all stood up and cheered
and were hugging each other
at the end maybe because we had been
there for 24 hours
and maybe because we were able to endure
it i don't know what it was but it was a
feeling of of exaltation
it was amazing
i've never experienced that before
because when i saw it normally you would
just walk out at some point or if you
were there like it's six o'clock at
night at eight o'clock the guy would
come in and go okay folks we have to
close it down the museum is closing
so there was no
like
experience
but for that there was it was amazing
did you stay up the full 24 hours
that was the when it did the last show
they specifically said it was going to
be 24 hours
before it was at the museum
you could only see it during the museum
hours
consequently you were only seeing
like if the museum opened at nine
the first image you saw was nine o'clock
and as the day wore on it would be ten
one three five you could stay from nine
to eight
but you you'd still miss a lot and i
never did stay more than four hours
so when i went i would stay three maybe
four hours and i'd go with friends and
we would get loaded or something and
watch it or something but
that last night when it was going to be
24 hours i
made i plan to be there for the whole
thing
i think there was one point where i knew
i had seen that
twice
an hour i'd seen it twice
and i left and got myself something to
eat and then i came back
my seat got taken so i had to stand
against the wall but then eventually
someone left and i sat down
it was amazing read about it
the clock
check it out google it
you